hi I'm Greg and I'm Mitch and we are a
SAP sign I'm Bernie from Russia cheese
I'm Matt Pat from game theory and film
theory that way the slow mo guys we're
to answer Google questions we are doing
a Google autocomplete interview our
youtubers revolutionising entertainment
the short answer I like to think so
well that's what going around if you
want to watch every single video on
YouTube you would fall two and a half
weeks behind every minute if you try to
do that it's an enormous amount of
content all YouTube is narcissistic our
youtubers considered celebrities the new
type of celebrities kind of again a very
niche celebrity like if we ever do get
recognized it's like one person like
screaming at us and then you're left on
a subway ride cause people like what I
think it's a hard line generationally
the younger people watch all our content
on YouTube and older people watch almost
none of their content on YouTube all
YouTube is rude well he's a piece of
geez our youtubers in the Illuminati I
have no comment who since you is your
tuba job oh is it ever like I hope it's
a job that's my job I think this YouTube
educational depends of a party YouTube
period friends we go to youtube all the
time we want to learn about how to fix
things in our house yeah well I need
hire time it's time you go fix something
just looking for you to do that you'll
send out how squidgy my face is whenever
something that's useful to me very
squishy faces swish your face is you to
diagnose I don't think so heavy question
don't kid yourself nothing better has
come along yet is YouTube addictive
without question it's a dictum in a good
way especially if you're on educational
content where all that dopamine in your
brain
we got more oh man they just keep coming
here we go does Fame bring you happiness
I don't know you'd have to ask someone
famous
it's nice when people come up to you and
say I love your videos very flattering
this Fame matter no think so yeah I
think you can be happy if you've blown
it privacy especially let's imagine how
much you missed away does Fame ruin your
life
this is really our kid hurry it depends
completely on the individual if it ruins
a lot if they let it burn your life I'd
say a candy if you've managed it
incorrectly does Fame equal success in
the age of Kim Kardashian it's hard to
argue otherwise but no Fame by itself
for me does not equal success does Fame
mean gee yeah however yeah
our YouTube celebrities educated maybe
not formally educated there is being an
editor and writer and personality
there's also like running your own
business hiring people tax law there's
people who make makeup tutorials fashion
vlogs gaming videos they're experts in
what they do like there's a lot to learn
I want to see how many of these answers
I can say it's a mixed bag it's a mixed
bag our YouTube celebrities entitled to
a private life I think everyone's
entitled to a private life but maybe
it's gonna change he decides to sign up
to become all YouTube celebrity AHS good
role models it's a mixed bag hexa makes
/ yeah our YouTube celebrities just like
us yeah yeah everyone started off doing
what they love and they're just doing
what they love at a much higher level I
think that keeps it very genuine our
YouTube celebrities perfect
he's anyone truly perfect is ASAP
science oh yeah that's not a lot
actually no not we applaud everyone who
is vegetarian or vegan I feel bad about
yes what are the slow mo guys cameras
cameras that we use a called phantoms
are cameras film like five thousand
frames seconds
what is Burnie burns real name you'll
never know disappoint to be able to the
time here let's clear the air right now
no I'm not a brony
is a sec science yeah gay with each
other
yeah what are the slow mo guys rocket
launchers so a very early video
basically got a drain pipe from the side
of the house taped up what hate up one
end just put a fire looking at that I
suppose is what we used is rocket
launcher
don't do
home disease up science accurate what we
do is we synthesize information from
people who devote their lives to like
very fascinating in-depth topics
what is Burnie burns Oh Schubert's on
The Amazing Race they put me in gold hot
pants and now those pictures live
forever
his matpat hauls maybe not ha levels
maybe just h.o.t matpat cod Wow
here's the thing I am visible in this
video so if you want an answer to it you
have only to look at the computer screen
in front of you what's other slow mo
guys names my name is Gavin I'm done
nobody shame on all of you we really
some that stuff is really weird Google
can't answer every question that's the
moral of today friends and with that I'm
Matt Pat and this has been my Google
autocomplete interview I survived thanks
for watching